[MUSIC]
JUAN CARLOS PINZON: Hola,
un saludos especiales.
NELLIE GORBEA: Hola,
Bienvenidos a Adelante Tigres.
MARGARITA ROSA:
Bienvenidos.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: It's my
pleasure to welcome you
back to Princeton
for Adelante Tigres.
GERSON LEIVA: Bienvenidos,
Adelante Tigres.
YVONNE GONZALEZ ROGERS &
MARIA ROGERS: Adelante Tigres.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: These
alumni conferences
have been important
ways for Princeton
to reflect on its
past, to reflect
on what we've done
right and to reflect
wrong, and to understand
what it is that we need to do
going into a complicated future
to be an even better and
more welcoming and inclusive
place than we've
been in the past.
Those topics, of course, are
especially important today.
There's a lot of
discussion in the world,
important discussion,
taking place
about issues around immigration,
inclusivity and equality.
And one of the
things that gets me
excited about this
conference is our opportunity
to talk about those issues
in terms that are personal,
in terms that are scholarly.
And I look forward to joining
you in those conversations.
MARGARITA ROSA:
Coming to Princeton
and being such a
minority, I was a minority
as a woman, a minority
as a person of color,
a minority as a
low-income person,
was jarring and at the
same time, inspiring,
because I took the
opportunity to learn
a lot more about my own culture.
MANUEL DEL VALLE: We knew
what our identity was.
We were looking for
access for ourselves,
our culture and values.
MARGARITA ROSA: The group split
into the Accion Puertorriquena
and I believe it was
the Chicano Caucus
and the Cuban organization.
And somewhere along
the line I was
elected to be the first
president of Accion
Puertorriquena.
MANUEL DEL VALLE: So
in terms of the goal:
to institutionalize Latino
experience at Princeton,
include us, not ignore
us and not exclude us.
And that's a function
of analyzing who we are
and where we are.
And it was easier to get
other like-minded students
from Mexico, from
L.A., from New Mexico,
to arrive at the
same conclusion.
MARGARITA ROSA: We
would pave the way
and help others from similar
backgrounds become aware
of the opportunity, be
encouraged to attend,
and also be supported
while they were here.
NELLIE GORBEA: I initially
didn't have Princeton
actually on my list
because I thought
it was somewhat unattainable.
JOSE ALVAREZ: It all
had to do with a guy who
went to my high school
a few years back who
had come from Princeton as part
of one of these college fairs.
YVONNE GONZALEZ ROGERS: What
brought me to Princeton
were actually teachers.
So when I was in
the seventh grade
I had a history teacher whose
name was Mr. Ludwikowski
and he was a Marine.
And he said to me, you
know, you're a smart kid.
You should think about going
to a place like Princeton.
NELLIE GORBEA: I went
and visited the campus
and I was thrilled by the
community that I saw there.
It was supportive,
but was also engaged
with the rest of the campus.
JOSE ALVAREZ: And I just became
enamored by what was available.
YVONNE GONZALEZ: And I
received the brochure
and the trifold pamphlet and
fell in love with Princeton
and what I read about it.
So it was the only
school I applied
to other than the
University of Texas
at Austin, where I
had a full scholarship
for the honors program.
JOSE ALVAREZ: I applied
early, I got in.
And then all of my friends and
relatives, parents and brothers
and sisters said,
well, that's great,
but how are you
going to pay for it?
YVONNE GONZALEZ:
In my view there
was no other choice to go
anywhere other than Princeton.
JOSE ALVAREZ: Obviously,
things worked out.
The incredibly generous
alums of Princeton University
made it possible for me to
get through the University.
That's true for
my wife, as well.
My wife comes from a working-class
family and the University
and the alumni made it
possible for her and for me
to get through this
incredible place.
NELLIE GORBEA:
The Latino student
organizations tended to serve
as a real cohesive space,
but it was not, like I said,
an exclusive community.
Most of us roomed with
people who were not Hispanic.
I was involved in other
organizations as well.
For example, I was a member of
the Princeton equestrian team.
I was part of the Russian
club in my first few years.
So we all did other
things, as well.
So you know it's a very
tumultuous time in your life
as you're trying to
make out who you are
and what you're going to
do with the rest of it.
GERMAN LARA: For any student
at Princeton, going to college
is something you have to
acclimate yourself to.
And every student at
Princeton, regardless
of nationality or ethnic origin,
has to make that adjustment.
IRMA MARTINEZ: Students
today I'm sure struggle, too,
but it's just part of being
young and being 18, 19, 20,
and feeling kind
of alienated here.
And I do feel like we were.
DAVID MEJIAS: In
the fall of 1995,
there was a call
for students who
were interested in ethnic
studies, what we had identified
at the time as Latino and
Asian American studies,
to attend a meeting at
the Third World Center.
And it was a pretty
active, lively discussion
on what we needed
to do as a community
to ensure that we made progress
with these two programs,
these two initiatives.
So as a result of that
meeting, a suggestion
was made that we think
about the idea of a sit-in.
We proceeded to set a date
for the sit-in and 17 of us
gathered and walked
into Nassau Hall
and that's where we
spent the day and a half
voicing our concerns.
At the end of the
sit-in, the students who
were working as the negotiators
met with the administration
and felt that their needs,
their specific concerns
were addressed.
The University made a
commitment to allocate funds
for professorships in the areas
of Latino and Asian American
studies
and also allocated funds
to develop curriculum
in those two areas.
MARTA TIENDA: We had
strong leaders at the time
of the student organizations.
They wanted to have
a Latino studies
program where they could at
least earn a certificate.
The importance of the
intellectual domain
asking the questions,
not let's compare Latinos
to whites, blacks and others,
which is an important exercise,
but what can we learn
about labor markets
by studying Latinos.
What can we learn about
language acquisition
by studying bilingualism?
What can we learn
about education systems
and how they are not
operating effectively
by studying Latinos.
That's a different way
of phrasing it, posing
the question, which is what
I try to do, rather than say
oh, it's our turn.
Let's add another column
to the comparison.
Adelante means forward, onward.
I think it's an
important opportunity
to see where the University
is, because the University is
an institution that continues
to grow, develop and change.
And whatever the
alumni got out of it,
they still have an opportunity
to give back and call and forge
the next generation.
The students who come
here are second to none
when we think about the big
distribution of possibilities
and opportunities.
And to participate in
shaping that I think
is a phenomenal opportunity.
JEREMY BORJON: As a graduate
student, being a Latino,
the experience is fundamentally
different as an undergraduate.
And there's a few reasons
why that's the case.
The biggest one is we're older.
We have more life experiences.
Our priorities are
completely different.
JUAN CARLOS PINZON:
It was great to join
other international students
coming from everywhere
in the world with their own
stories, with their own lives,
with their own vision,
with their own experience.
SARA LOPEZ: Getting to
know everybody in my class
and maintaining
those friendships
has been just one of the
best lessons in life.
Sorry, I get a little choked
up when I talk about Princeton.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
IRMA MARTINEZ: Ballet
Folklórico de Princeton.
It's Mexican folk dance music.
It's beautiful.
Each state in Mexico
has their own tradition
of the music and the costumes.
GERSON LEIVA: We
went about starting
the first urban Latin dance
company on campus called
the Más Flow Dance Company.
And within four years, it
became one of the biggest dance
companies on this campus.
We danced the traditional salsa,
merengue, bachata, kizomba,
samba.
And we always, always
encourage our members
to take on a choreography.
JEREMY BORJON: I
brought with me today
two pictures from graduation.
My mom, my grandma in the
middle, and my tia, then
my Uncle Raymundo and myself.
And unfortunately,
my Uncle Raymundo
passed away about
three years ago.
And everything I'm doing
is to honor his memory
and also to honor the
three amazing women who
raised me to who I am today.
GERSON LEIVA: My
parents migrated
from El Salvador in the
'80s during the civil war.
And it wasn't easy for them.
And this is something that when
I wake up day-to-day basis,
it's something I think about.
I have a ton of opportunities
that they didn't.
And so now I'm focused on
making the most of them.
I don't think I'll ever face as
much adversity as they faced.
And when I think about who
I want to become in life,
I want to become them.
I want to be able to
overcome everything,
no matter what
life throws at me.
JEREMY BORJON: A lot of people
had told my mom that she
wasn't raising me right.
That I was reading
too many books
and I had too many
grandiose ideas,
I lived too much to debate
and to argue as opposed
to actually going out and
doing work with my hands.
GERSON LEIVA: I feel as though
I have that responsibility now
to go back and show the
people that, in my community,
that it's possible to do
big things, to dream big.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PEDRO PABLO KUCZYNSKI:
I am happy to be here.
I'm honored to be
in this ceremony.
MARISA SALAZAR:
What stood out to me
were the diverse, vibrant,
interconnected communities
from which Princeton
was formed and which
have shaped my time here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
IRMA MARTINEZ: I
first became involved
in ALPA, which is the
Association of Latino Princeton
Alumni, it's been about
seven, eight years.
We started to put
a working board
together and having
elections and reconnecting
with alums, fellow alums and
the current students here.
And actually that
helped me understand
that I am a Princetonian.
GERMAN LARA: I do think
it's important for alumni
and for students
to know that there
are Latino alumni on
the Board of Trustees.
YVONNE GONZALEZ ROGERS: When the
alumni elected me University trustee,
I think I was in
a state of shock
that I was actually coming
back to Princeton as a trustee.
I was amazed that a
Mexican American kid from San
Antonio, Texas, could ever come
back to a place like Princeton
and be trustee.
I was incredibly humbled to be
offered that position of trust.
MARGARITA ROSA: I'm very
grateful to Sonia Sotomayor,
who was here when
I was here and who
told me when my
daughter was going
to come here that I shouldn't
let anybody else bring her.
She wanted to bring her here.
And a year or two ago, she
told a story at Alumni Day.
SONIA SOTOMAYOR: One of my
most joyous moments of my life
was helping Margarita bring
her daughter, Marisol,
to Princeton.
MARGARITA ROSA: It was
that moment of separation
from your child.
And so to have a friend, a
dear friend, who had been here
with me who was very proud
and happy that my daughter was
coming.
Who had actually brought
her things to the campus
and then sat with me
as I sort of sniffled
when I walked away and realized
that my little girl was now
a college student, was
really very, very sweet.
DAVID MEJIAS: I was very moved
to see Sonia Sotomayor's quote
engraved in the middle of campus
greens in front of Nassau Hall.
That, to me, is emblematic
of what this conference means
and what it's going to
allow Latino alumni to do.
SONIA SOTOMAYOR: Princeton
in the nation's service,
in the service of all
nations, and in the service
of humanity, one person
and one act at a time.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: I tremendously
enjoyed the alumni conferences
that we've had in the past,
and I've been looking forward
to this one all year long.
I've already enjoyed
the opportunity
to talk to some of you about
your experiences on the campus
while you were here and
what they meant to you.
I really enjoyed talking
to Charlie Hey when I was
down in Puerto Rico last year.
And he at the time
gave me a copy
of Bacalao, the
newsletter that he
and Sonia Sotomayor
and others put out
while they were on the campus.
His stories about that
time were tremendous
and it'll be wonderful over
the course of the next few days
to hear you talk about
your time at Princeton
and to hear about the tapestry
of the Latino community
as all of you moved through
Princeton and into your alumni
careers.
I look forward to
talking to you.
Welcome back to Princeton.
Adelante Tigres.
[MUSIC PLAYING]